people ask
it's an interesting question let me know
if you have any recommendations what
three books
technical or fiction or philosophical
had an impact
on your life or you would recommend
perhaps uh
maybe we'll start with the least
controversial uh infinite jest
um infinite jest is a
david foster wallace yeah it's a book
about wireheading really
very enjoyable to read very uh
well-written
you know you will you will you will grow
as a person reading this book
uh it's effort um and i'll set that up
for the second book which is pornography
it's called atlas shrugged um
which um atlas drug is pornography i
mean it is
i will not i will not defend the i will
not say atlas shrugged is a well-written
book
it is entertaining to read certainly
just like pornography
the production value isn't great um you
know there's a 60 page
monologue in there that ann rand's
editor really wanted to take out
and she uh paid she paid out of her
pocket
to keep that 60 page monologue in the
book um
but it is a great book for a kind of
framework um of human relations
and i know a lot of people are like yeah
but it's a terrible framework
yeah but it's a framework just for
context
in a couple days i'm speaking with for
probably four plus hours with euron
brook who's
the main living remaining objectivists
objectivist interesting uh so
i've always found this philosophy quite
interesting on many levels one of how
repulsive
some percent of large percent of the
population find it
which is always uh always funny to me
when people
are like unable to even read a
philosophy
because um of some i think that says
more about their psychological
perspective on it
yeah but but there is something about
objectivism and iran's philosophy that's
very deeply connected to this idea of
capitalism
of uh the ethical life is the productive
life
um that was always um
compelling to me it didn't seem as like
i didn't seem to interpret it in the
negative sense that some people do
to be fair i read that book when i was
19. so you had an impact at that point
yeah
yeah and the the bad guys in the book
have this slogan from each according to
their ability to each according to their
need
and i'm looking at this and i'm like
these are the most cards this is team
rocket level cartoonishness
right no bad guy and then when i
realized that was actually the slogan of
the communist party
i'm like wait a second wait no no no no
no just you're telling me this really
happened
yeah it's interesting i mean one of the
criticisms of her work is she
has a cartoonish view of good and evil
like
that there's like the the reality isn't
jordan peterson says is that
each of us have the capacity for good
and evil in us as opposed to like
there's some characters who are purely
evil and some characters are purely good
and that's in a way why it's
pornographic
the production value i love it well evil
is punished and there's very clearly
you know there's no there's no you know
uh just like porn doesn't have uh you
know like character growth well you know
neither does alex shrugged like
brilliant well put but as a 19 year old
george hunts it was
it was good enough yeah yeah yeah what
uh what's the third
or something um i i could give these
these two i'll just throw out uh there's
sci-fi uh permutation city
um great things to start thinking about
copies of yourself and then um
that is uh greg egan
uh he's uh that might not be his real
name some australian guy might not be
australian
i don't know um and then this one's
online it's called the metamorphosis of
prime intellect
um it's a story set in a
post-singularity world it's interesting
is there uh can you if either of the
worlds do you find something
philosophically interesting in them that
you can comment on
i mean it is clear to me that uh
metamorphosis prime intellect is like
written by an engineer
uh which is
it's very it's very almost a pragmatic
take on a utopia in a way
positive or negative is it well that's
up to you to decide reading the book
and the ending of it is very interesting
as well and i didn't realize what it was
i first read that when i was 15. i've
reread that book several times in my
life
and it's sure it's 50 pages everyone
should go read it
what's uh sorry it's a little tangent
i've been working through the foundation
i've been i've haven't read much sci-fi
my whole life and i'm trying to fix that
the last few months that's been a little
side project
what's uh to use the greatest sci-fi
novel
uh that uh people should read or is that
or
i mean i would yeah i would i would say
like yeah permutation city metamorphosis
environmental i got it
um i don't know i i didn't like
foundation uh i thought it was way too
modernist
i feel like dune i've never read dune
i've never read dune i have to read it
uh fire upon the deep is
interesting uh
okay i mean look everyone should read
everyone you're reading a romance
everyone should read snow crash
if you haven't read those like start
there um yeah i haven't read snow
questions
yeah no it means very entertaining go to
lecture bach and if you want the
controversial one
bronze age mindset
all right i'll look into that one those
aren't sci-fi
but just to round out books
you